all right this is a center sensitivity
drill okay and so a lot of times you
know
you it's like we pull on the arm and
then eventually it pulls on the center
you guys see that so I I'm going to pull
on the arm and now you can feel that I
have kind of that you see and then
eventually I start to pull it outside
and then eventually it pulls down you
see that that's not that's not it okay
so at the moment of contact is what you
want to feel so I don't have to do
anything with this position you see this
this
position uh if you want to project I
just have to increase the Y value
okay so again just fine I'll find it w
okay and then you from from here you
kind you can just start moving that
thing see you're going just start moving
you just start moving it moving
it okay you can start dropping
it dropping
it
okay understand okay so in this drill
you have the easy one where you pull the
skin
suit okay and you know you get some some
stuff here you get some Ledges but
you're still pulling the suit you're
still pulling the skin
[Music]
suit what you're going to do is Boom
Center connection and you're keeping
that Center I'm starting to lower the
center so I know if I go this way I'm
going to come a little of he got I got a
little down and now it's off see so you
got to be careful I I feel what I'm
feeling and that's where I go so again
if I go this way do skin suit okay I'll
feel it feel it feel it I keep feeling
in
it try to keep that feeling okay so boom
in don't look
for a a skin suit
pull right or some weird lever here okay
it's just in feel that and just start
manipulating it till you can get it to
do what we want it to do
okay I don't want you to go fast or feel
feel feel feel feel feel feel feel
feel again it's not important what what
your hand is doing so you're like oh I
think you got to turn the hand you can
turn the hand over no you're just going
to figure out how to do this
okay okay got it all right let's try so
every is different it doesn't M it
doesn't matter just like the contact
point doesn't matter okay so for for
example uh so here here I have you can
feel that right but as I try to start
turning it do you see how he turned his
hips you see that so he he felt we
demonstrate it again so I'm going to do
the thing so he feels my center and he
feels me start to take balance and he's
absorbing the energy do you see okay
I didn't want him to do that but it
doesn't matter so I got to figure out so
I go I go that way okay but I still have
that Center you see okay now if I start
pushing again he's going backwards do
you see do you see that okay so I know
that's not going to do what I
want look I come
forward see then
now okay it's not ideal I wish you
wouldn't do that cuz he's countering but
that makes better training because
because the center will be dynamic like
that you get what I'm saying so um your
question of like what is UK doing if he
does that I'm still going to do it get
it but what UK is not
doing is he goes and I just lock up do
you see I I just because I
am the the connection
point and and then the metric by which
he gains his
sensitivity right I actually don't do
that if I start doing some weird thing
myself okay but he has to get that okay
and he's he's pulling on my hand you're
pulling on the skin suit you have to
find my Center okay he's pushing on it
it's fine but I'm probably not going to
go down okay there he
goes okay so again keep keep it keep it
come on I can talk you do what you need
to he's pushing me back you see it's not
going to make me go down but he did have
it okay he's got it here if he pays
attention I'm on my heels don't lose the
feeling okay so let's say for example I
start uh freeing the energy go back so I
can't move my arm I can't I can't do
that I'm not allowed for the rules to
disconnect but I can't also open my arm
do you see okay but let's I did like you
would do to me okay and I start to open
my arm you still keep my Center as the
arm opens let it open and keep the
feeling of my weight on my Center I'm
trying to open it and you just keep
going with it and you can see I never
really get that joint Freedom you and
I'm still having my Center affected by
him okay
um so I'm here he's going to find my
Center
you got to get some there he goes okay
cool and I'm just keeping it and you
should hurry
up cuz the more I move out you're going
to lose
it find the set pushing me back that's
all you're doing you got to get me to
tilt there okay cool you're pulling on
the skin suit so try not to counter this
time okay keep your feet where they are
okay you see okay so as you start to
like you're starting to lean out like
you were I just keep that
connection you see that as he's falling
so I want you to
feel that at some point I don't go down
anymore I'm going to cut in okay so
we'll do it again don't move don't
counter the technique there there's your
Center you're going to feel that go out
okay got it and as you go
out you feel that push come out so I
don't go to the skin suit
there he goes I kind of have it and then
I go to SK I feel that difference just
pull it on the wrist okay then I gave up
his Center again okay
so I don't the Only Rule for UK is hey
don't let go okay but don't do anything
else okay not even the counter I prefer
but if you're higher skill take
advantage of your UK is doing that kind
of stuff okay and if you feel that
you're losing connection based on what
they're doing it's because you didn't
stay up with it got it okay try I'm not
going to take you down okay um but
you're like trying to do a technique you
see and you get some leverage on here
and then but you're really just pulling
all the skin you see okay so remember I
did one
rep do you guys remember I did one rep
without having to do a mechanical so
we're here like that and I'm in already
okay you see and I don't need to do
anything with my hand with my arm or
your arm okay so here we'll do like that
you see no I'm not in yet okay there we
go okay and now I just keep adjusting
this thing you see okay and you're going
to eventually move and I don't go
oh now I have the ledge I want okay so I
didn't make the ledge and then push the
ledge okay the ledge happened because
we're move you're moving you see that
your arm is doing that thing okay and
then I keep in that Center so I'm not
going to tell you okay so pull in same
thing do you see you could go this way
you see you could go this way it's not
that I turn your arm I just I have you
here and I move that you see okay so
find that instead of finding this ledge
that you could now do Zoom what you
think isum okay all right again if
you're if you're just doing the the
center connection that that's that was
it that's it okay um but what we're
doing with the fall is as he falls the
center connection has to change you see
because it's changing okay and then you
have to not smell the skin suit pull
okay you want to keep the center
connection you guys thought that's why
we task ourselves with the fall when you
when you look at the fall as you control
the
center right we know that his lower Tom
Den is
also um I don't know the word is
skipping my mind right now but I think
it's congruent it's congruent with his
center of gravity got it uh in this case
due to how where he's standing how he's
standing and that means his line of
gravity got it is in a particular place
so as I move his Center a particular way
I in order to stay up with it I'm going
to make that Center gravity as I
manipulate the lower tonden the center
gravity is now moving in the sagittal
plane that means his line of gravity is
moving right in the sagittal plane on
the mat and I keep putting it outside
his Bas of support just ever so slightly
and that's what makes the fall and now
allows for a dynamic Center connection
okay so if we if we are doing for
example edag you can see I I I you can
feel that right and I do the same thing
it's all the same it's the same like
moving his center around you see okay
and now I still from here I move this
Center and just crush
it I'm not crushing the guy that's
standing straight up and just ever so
slightly pushing the lower tanden
down in a place where the center of
gravity and the line is is outside his
Bas of support so the line of gravity is
outside the Bas this support you got it
and so I'm not going like
this
see that's different okay you you have
the connection you move the censor and
you crush okay and the turn that we see
in the other one is me turning to stay
in the back it's not me turning to crush
this the the center okay so uh you have
the center move the
C I stay in the back
okay
so I'm not going to turn and just do the
crush okay
[Music]
so got it just sink the chi with this
geometry and it just drops okay let's
try just like you you you wanted those
Ledges you know you got it and you
wanted the the skin suit pulls you you
you don't do that here you you have a
center okay and now you I have a center
here you
see so I have a center I have a center I
have a center what do you want
him you understand so you guys are going
on and
off some of you have that okay then you
go off you see and you're off then you
come back here and then you go here you
understand
no
Center B Center Center
down don't come up to the shoulders I
don't know if I did that last time it's
probably because I was talking and I I I
lost the connection on his arm but in
the technique you'd have that arm I
would I would have this I would have
that arm see you'd have that arm you get
it so that's that's my connection
point okay try it
again okay so and part of your Tachi is
that you start that tilt because that's
your zone of sanctuary and your angle
cancellation he should not be standing
straight up do you guys get it so when
you move his Center you have that tilt
and that he has to now move forward with
the Tilt he can't move forward
straight when you have the Tilt that's
what you move
forward you see and you're in that tilt
okay now let's say your
UK wants to pull up and walk forward do
do you understand that so show what that
would look like okay cool
that's just more Dynamic movement that I
use to control the center he tries to do
it walk forward like you want and you
guide that down or let's
say he wants to sit his butt
down you
see as as he sits his butt
down are keeping that same Center
control just
like as he did all this crazy stuff you
still keep the same thing and it's a
dynamic process okay it's not that
you're going to go
here and then you're just going to you
have to keep connection to the center no
matter what he does so he walks whatever
way and I have to keep the
feeling okay he tries to go around like
he's trying to turn got it he tries to
turn like keep the
feeling
there no different than the hand drill
okay try